hi everyone welcome to today's episode
of your daily equation and today I'm
gonna focus upon an equation that I feel
doesn't get enough air time when people
talk about the strangeness of space and
time and relativity because it's an
equation that directly addresses the
kind of question that I at least have
asked all the time by people who
encounter these strange ideas especially
the idea of the constant nature of the
speed of light because look we all have
in our ingrained intuition the following
fact right
if you run toward an object that's
approaching you it will approach you
faster and if you run away from an
object that's approaching you it will
approach you slower right and yet we
know that that intuition cannot be
completely true because if the object
that's approaching you is a beam of
light then that would suggest that by
running toward it you could make the
speed of approach faster than the speed
of light
and if you run away from the approaching
beam it should make the speed of
approach slower but the constant nature
of the speed of light says that that
can't be true so how do we reconcile
these ideas and today's rather beautiful
and simple mathematical equation will
show us how I'm Stein's theory copes
with this tension and makes complete
sense of it ok so let's jump right in
and I'll begin with a little again kind
of silly story that just gets our mind
in the right perspective for the ideas
that we're discussing so what is the
story so imagine that there's a nice
little game of catch happening between
George and Gracie and say George's
throwing that football toward Gracie at
5 meters per second then Gracie receives
it at 5 meters per second nothing tricky
about that but now imagine the next day
George comes out with not a football but
an egg and Gracie is not fond of playing
catch with eggs so what does she do she
turns and runs because of that intuition
by running away the speed of approach of
the egg will be lessened it will be made
smaller indeed putting some numbers
behind it if the egg is flying in the
horizontal direction toward Gracie at
five meters per second
and she runs away say three minutes per
second and we all know in our intuition
that the egg should be approaching her
with a net speed of two meters per
second and in the reverse situation - if
Gracie loved playing catch with eggs and
couldn't resist the wait for the egg to
reach her and she ran toward George at
say the same speed three meters per
second then we all have in our tuition
that the egg would approach her at five
plus three meters per second or eight
meters per second and the tension then
comes in when we think about these ideas
apply to the speed of light so let me
show you that let me bring up my iPad
here so what's the basic formula that
Gracie and George and we are making use
of the basic formula is that if an
object is approaching you say at V
meters per second when you are
stationary and if you run away from it
then if you run at a speed W with
respect to the ground say that initial
frame of reference then the - W this
should be the speed of approach in that
circumstance and the reverse that I also
mentioned if the objects of the egg is
approaching at a speed V and you run
toward it with a speed W then you should
have a net speed of approach of V plus W
and the tension that I'm mentioning just
to make it explicit is what if you don't
have a football you don't have an egg
but rather you say have a beam of light
so now the initial speed of approach is
C in both of these cases and if you run
away or run toward the beam of light
with the speed W
then the speed of approach from this
reasoning should be C minus W which
would be of course less than C or C plus
W run toward the beam of light and that
of course is greater than C and that's
the problem speeds less than the speed
of light or speed greater than speed of
light when you are encountering a beam
of light whose speed is meant to be
constant independent of your motions how
do we make sense of this well the basic
idea that Einstein tells us is that even
this very simple formula that we're all
familiar with from elementary physics or
even just elementary logic is actually
wrong it works really well at speeds
that are much less than the speed of
light and that's why we all hold it in
our intuition but Einstein actually
taught us that each of these formula
needs a correction let me show you what
the correction is is that is today's
daily equation so instead of V minus W
Einstein says that the correct formula
of the speed of approach if you're
running away from the object at speed
that has been being you're running away
s VW is corrected by 1 minus V times W
divided by C squared and the V plus W
formula gets a very similar correction
and that correction just has the other
sign in fact you could do these all
together with one formula that just had
the plus sign if you love the speeds
have positive and negative values but
let me just keep it simple and imagine
that all the speeds involved are
positive being W positive numbers so
these are the formula they're
effectively the same formula just with
the two cases that we are writing down
separately and that is the so-called
relativistic velocity combination law
and now let me just show you how this
works if for example you are taking V to
be equal to
see now you're not throwing the egg or
the football but you're throwing or
shining perhaps is a better word a beam
of light so the case where you run away
Gracie say runs away from the beam of
light we give a C minus W over 1 minus C
times W over C squared and what does
that equal
well look we can write this as C minus W
over 1 minus W over C and we can write
that as C times just pull out a see
upstairs 1 minus W over C divided by 1
minus W over C and now you see that that
1 minus W over C factor cancels in the
top and the bottom and that then gives
us the net result is equal to C that's
that's fantastic so by running away from
the beam of light Gracie does not
decrease the speed of approach of the
light this correction factor that
Einstein gives us over here has this
wonderful effect of ensuring that the
combined velocity is still equal to C
and as you can imagine and I don't even
need to go through it I can just put
plus signs in here if Gracie was running
toward the beam of light all the
analysis would have a plus there and
you'd again have this cancellation and
you get speed of light again as your
result if grace is running toward the
oncoming beam of light that George
shines at her now that's the special
case where V is equal to C it's fun to
use this formula even in other
circumstances imagine that you have an
object that is being fired at you say at
3/4 the speed of light and let's say you
run toward it at 3/4 the speed of light
just sort of for the fun of it
now you're naive classical intuition
would tell you that the net speed from
your perspective would be 3/4 the speed
of light plus 3/4 of the speed of light
it's coming toward you and you're
running toward it the speeds would
combine
in the intuitive way of doing these
kinds of calculations but of course that
number would be six quarters of the
speed of light that's bigger than the
speed of light problem well what does
Einstein do he says hang on you need to
correct this by 1 plus VW over C squared
VW now is 3/4 C times 3/4 of C divided
by C squared and now we can work this
out upstairs we have the offending six
quarters of the speed of light but what
if we get downstairs downstairs we get
one plus 3/4 times 3/4 is 9 over 16 and
the C Squared's cancel so we get six
quarters C times what's 1 plus 9 over 16
well this guy over here just gives us 16
over 16 plus 9 over 16 which is 25 over
16 which we can bring that upstairs as
16 over 25 and now the 4 goes in here
and we get 2000 I left out the C we get
24 over 25 times C less than the speed
of light so the offensive term six
quarters time the speed of light is
reduced by the correction factor to 24
over 25 times the speed of light less
than C and that will always be the case
whatever numbers you put in to this
relativistic velocity combination
formula it will always yield a net speed
from your perspective from say Gracie's
perspective that is less than the speed
of light regardless of the speeds that
are put into that format as long as each
such speed is less than or equal to the
speed of light so it's a beautiful
formula and it shows us it actually
shows us indeed just going back to the
initial little scenario that we start
with with George and Gracie say with the
egg so in that case in fact let me just
bring this up for the heck of it because
it's kind of fun to see so in that
particular case we had V equals 2/5 not
going to put
units in and W say was equal to three
and we did this little calculation that
five minus three equals two I'll put it
in meters per second meters per second
looks funny to me otherwise meters per
second meters per second so that was the
calculation that we did in everyday life
but Einsteins telling us even in
everyday life you need to include this
correction so what is the actual speed
of the approaching egg from Gracie's
perspective well you do five minus three
meters per second upstairs but now you
must divide by one minus five meters per
second times three meters per second
divided by the speed of light squared
which of course in meters per second is
a nice big number three times 10 to the
eighth meters per second so what is this
correction factor
well the correction factor is of course
quite small or I should say differs from
one by a little bit it's one minus this
really tiny number that we have over
here which you know C squared is you
know about ten to the seventeen so call
this on the order of a correction factor
in the sixteenth decimal place or so ten
to the minus sixteen or so so the net
effect is that this number two that we
have over here is actually increased by
a little bit because you're dividing
through by a number which is itself less
than one it's very close to one only
differs from one way down and say the
15th or 16th decimal place but it is a
little bit less than one which means
that this two would be a little bit
bigger than two so the speed of approach
even in everyday life in that simple
silly scenario of the egg approaching
Gracie she runs away her intuitive
calculation is close to correct but it's
not completely correct the effects of
relativity are always there they're just
really small typically at everyday
speeds but they are there and they
matter and they show us how when the
speeds approach or impact or equal to
the speed of light everything
combines in just the right way to give
net speeds that are always less than or
equal to the speed of light
just as relativity requires okay that's
all I had to say for today this
beautiful relativistic velocity
combination law that allows us to
correct our intuition for how speeds
combine making everything compatible
with the speed of light being the
maximum speed limit making the world
safe Brian Stein Ian relativity ok until
next time take care this is your daily
equation